the corridors of Power are a unique
workplace the long hours the demanding
ministers is it too hard to ask for help
how difficult is it right now for a
civil servant to raise a complaint about
a coward administer if you raise a
complaint against even the most senior
person a permanent secretary in your
department there's a process there if it
comes to complaining about ministers
there's nothing there's not even a
procedure there's nothing laid down
there's nothing written down you have
got to complain under the ministerial
code which means it goes to the Prime
Minister and the Prime Minister decides
whether it's even investigated the prime
is like it's a veto and this prime
minister has decided to retain that veto
ministers don't line manage civil
servants but there is a power dynamic in
a high pressure environment I think that
there is a generational issue
Caroline worked in the foreign office
and number 10 for seven years the
politicians who gets
are probably facing
um are having to live quite a robust
life you know they are they are
constantly being criticized they're
constantly
um undiscruciating they will feel quite
isolated sometimes I think in their in
their departments
um they will have a small political
staff around them who will be
responsible for ensuring that what they
are trying to do is indeed being done it
does mean that there's a potential
mismatch of expectations
two of The Bullying complaints against
Dominic Robb were upheld but it wasn't
totally clear-cut and it's brought up a
bigger debate Beyond Westminster about
the culture in the workplace and what is
deemed appropriate we've had a shift and
a move away from needing to prove that
somebody intends to upset you or cause
you serious distress and more of a focus
not a complete Focus but more of a focus
on how that conduct is received by the
individual I mean we're probably nothing
like as deferential to our bosses then
perhaps we were a generation ago and
that's a societal shift
in some ways it's probably a good thing
but in other ways there is that Clash
but the verdict on Dominic Robb is in he
was a bully of course he has to go this
black and white thing is get
tonight he's out of government the PM
says there were shortfalls in the
process it seems all sides agree on that
Ali Fortescue Sky News Westminster